when I was 27 I had just over a million
dollar in my bank account in cash by the
time I was 29 I had over 20 by the time
I was 31 it was more than that here's
how to get so rich you realize money was
never the point But first you have to
get rich there's three strategies and
the first one is building a brand so the
first time I saw the power of brand was
when he released a new product to my
existing distribution base of gyms which
was a software called aln which then
later became Allen there was a certain
percentage of gyms in my distribution
base who weren't able to attend the
launch or see the webinar live and what
ended up happening was crazy all of a
sudden we started getting hours later
calls and texts saying hey I heard that
Alex offered something here's my credit
card just sign me up for whatever it is
and I was like wait they haven't seen
the actual pitch the realization was
they just had a history of positive
experiences when giving me money that
they got more back that they were like
oh here's another time where I can give
money and get more value back great I'll
utilize the opportunity and so I was
like whoa this is something different
I've never had this before and so I was
like I need to protect this as much as
hum possible and is there ways that I
can do even more of it and so let me
give you four visual examples of how
branding even came to be and so back in
the day you'd have bulls look at my
beautiful Bulls those Bulls would
originally be unmarked and so people had
no way of differentiating between their
bulls and other people's Bulls they
started branding literally searing their
own logo or whatever into the bull and
so let's say we've got our our Nike bull
here great now we recognize that as a
logo and we like that person if we have
that experience then we're going to
treat the cow differently than if it
were unbranded now let's say that
there's a brand that we don't recognize
we would then treat this bull like all
other branded Bulls in that it's a
category that we just know that it
belongs to someone else the third
scenario might be let's say that it
belongs to somebody that you hate and so
we have branding that you recognize and
like well then you'd be nice to the cow
and take it home branding that you
recognize and hate you might capture the
cow kill the cow and eat it for yourself
or steal it branding of somebody you
don't recognize but know that in general
it belongs to someone which would then
change your behavior and then finally a
cow that was unbranded in general and
you would treat it like you treat all
cows that have no owner and so the
reason this is important is that
fundamentally the point of branding is
to change behavior of the person who
sees it all of this is an indication of
past experience it's saying hey treat me
like you would treat me like you'd want
to be treated treat that cow like you
would want to be treated uh which is
exactly the point no but the owner is is
is communicating something to anybody
else who sees the cow that's the point
we want to Brand our product so that
they treat it ideally like something
that people like and love which might
mean that they buy it quickly at higher
prices and over and over again and tell
their friends versus not buy it tell
people Terrible Things dissuade their
friends from buying it versus I don't
know maybe I'll take a risk on this
thing and then it's going to be the the
quality of the creative that's going to
have to communicate and this is again
why if you had a really fancy brand and
it looks high-end then they're just
going to extrapolate what they know
about high-end brands in general to the
purchase okay this looks like a premium
brand I understand why they're doing
these things but I don't have history
now if you make the purchase and they
have history then it would shift into
one of these two categories in a word
Steve Jobs describes brand as trust I
Define trust as predictive power based
on past experiences just as much as you
can trust someone to do a bad job you
can trust someone to do a good job and
so the idea here is obviously to build
trust that we will deliver on our
promises and so fundamentally you build
that by making promises and keeping or
overd delivering on the Promises you
have but brand is a big Amorphis topic
and so how do you measure this in
dollars and cents and so there's
basically three things that brand
translates to in terms of economics for
a business and so the first is
conversion rate now what does that mean
so conversion rate is the percentage of
people who when presented with your
offer choose to buy it and so let's say
that you have a bad brand or no brand at
all a bad brand would be that you have a
past history people trust you to do bad
stuff you have lower than neutral if you
have no brand it would be based on their
experience with other businesses that
look like yours and so this is also why
quote good branding even if you don't
have a history of reinforcement can
still be important because if you walk
talk and Quack Like Somebody who is a
scam artist you will have people treat
you like one it's not just your
experience but their experience with
people like you fundamentally like this
is what racism is about but people
prejudge people because that's how we go
through life if we had to start at zero
for every single person we met we would
use up all of the cognitive load that we
have and consumers like all humans try
to use shorthand we want to learn based
on the things put a label on it put in a
bucket and not think about it as fast as
possible and so from a conversion rate
perspective a good brand means that
let's say neutral would be let's say you
close 20% of people who you get on the
phone with at a specific price point at
negative uh which actually get that I'll
just put I'll put the zero here negative
one and then positive maybe and this the
thing here is that this could go as high
as you want like if you have an
unbelievable reputation like plus plus
plus maybe you close 80% and what's
interesting about this is if you look
and maybe here it's 0% because KN one
everyone hates you uh and you basically
have to rely on people who don't know
who you are advertise wider and wider to
find people who have yet to meet you
which is a terrible way to live so brand
gives you an increased percentage of
people who will buy when presented with
your offer just like the guy who didn't
even need to get presented with the
offer just knowing that I had an offer
he was willing to buy it and the reason
I use apple as a great litmus test for
this is that I think Steve Jobs was one
of the best brand builders of all time I
mean people lining up to buy whatever
his next product was because of his past
history of keeping his promises and
overd delivering on it and so number one
is conversion rate this is like if you
had nothing else this would be worth it
if you could forx the amount of people
that bought your stuff at a specific
price that would give you a material
advantage over everyone else but
branding doesn't stop there in terms of
its B business benefits the second is
CTR now it's like okay what does that
really mean so it's actually conversion
rate again but just earlier on in the
funnel and so let's say again you have
eyeballs you've got people who see your
promotions in whatever way you advertise
so that could be making content that
could be Outreach attempts responding to
emails basically the number of engaged
leads having a higher click the rate
means people take the first action they
then convert on a landing page or a you
know a Shopify page or whatever they're
either buying a product or they're
scheduling a call and then on the call
they have a higher conversion rate as
well and so basically you can think
about this is conversion rate throughout
the entire process from the beginning to
the money and then obviously if you
continue to do a good job on resales
repurchases Etc so let's say that
generically at1 one and then zero and
then plus here you might have a 5% click
theough rate and then here maybe you
have a 1% click through rate and then
maybe here you have something like a 3%
click through rate and this is super
standard like this happens all the time
especially if you're going after markets
that already know who you are when I
launched my leads book we had never run
ads before and so this was all novel and
there was a past history of the first
book so the first book has I think like
26,000 five stars at the point of making
this video there was a lot of
anticipation for the second book and so
the ctrs were like 6% for our ads and so
people were signing up for the book
launch for something like a dollar which
is crazy and I'd never had anything like
that before especially at scale and so I
was like man these are some of the
benefits of building trust with an
audience and so from the conversionary
perspective if you think about those
guys who bought at the aln launch who
weren't even presented the offer they
just found out that I had something to
sell those are people who otherwise in a
neutral or negative business certainly
wouldn't have purchased they would have
either needed to be convinced if they
were neutral or or they just would have
not wanted to buy to begin with if they
were at the negative side of the
spectrum that's how you can just
demonstrate visually what the experience
of having a higher conversion rate looks
like more people buy when they're
presented with the offer and I'll give
you another really tactical example my
offer is book on Amazon the actual page
itself converts at 30% so basically a
little bit less than one out of three
people who visits the page buys the book
now I think there's a variety of reasons
for that one of them is that many people
who go there got referred via Word of
Mouth which will get to one of the big
compounding things from that later but
the second thing is that even if you
don't have word of mouth when you have
you know a 4.9 rating and you've got
26,000 people who rated at that then you
have high confidence that it's going to
deliver at least a decent product now
the third Big Brand benefit is price
point and so this is one that I think is
probably more commonly touted and Warren
Buffett describes it like this he says
if you have to say a prayer before you
raise your prices by 10% you have a bad
business and so the idea is that if
customers love your product they will be
more will willing to pay a premium to
get it rather they are paying down the
risk of buying somebody else's product
and so they buy your product with the
existing promise and then the extra is
basically their insurance that they pay
you knowing that they're going to get
exactly what they expect I can't
overemphasize how important it is to pay
down people's risk like Risk is one of
the the three primary levers in terms of
value creation and so this is why
McDonald's for example even another
product in it of itself is not that good
it is consistent and consistency in it
of itself reduces risk and people just
like to have their expectations met now
what's interesting about this is that to
meet everyone's expectations it means
that you'll have to go really high
because some people have high
expectations some people have medium
some people have low expectations and so
if you want to meet the expectations of
a large percentage of the audience you
will have to try to overd deliver when
the people who are the most amending you
will simply have delivered now other
people you will have overd delivered for
but I think this idea of like you're
always going to overd deliver I don't
think is true I think you just have to
try as hard as you can and a larger
percentage of people will be satisfied
now with this price in any competitive
market if you can raise price by let's
say this is your revenue and this is
your profit before so this is our
neutral brand versus our plus plus brand
okay so let's say that they have the
same base economics so the cost of doing
business is the same between these two
businesses but this business can simply
charge
10% more by doing that they basically
double the amount of profit that they're
able to make as a result of their brand
there's one more point that makes brand
make you even more money and it just
took me way too long to realize this
because I got really good at marketing
and sales early and I came at it from
the perspective of like I just need to
go find more people when it's so much
more profitable to find the existing
people that you have that you already
have done business with and they want to
continue doing business with with you
and so I solve now for how do I get
people to always want to do business
with me again rather than how do I find
more people and so the fourth piece is
repurchases and so just like apple like
I was mentioning earlier they have such
an amazing system of getting people into
their ecosystem and then buying again
and again and again and it would take a
tremendous amount of effort to get
someone to
deconned of digital hardware and so the
fourth benefit is that not only do you
get more people to respond more people
to convert at higher prices so you can
make more profit that profit then gets
multiplied so if we have our our neutral
example let's put I'm going to have to
put the other one over here now we
already have a higher price point so
we're already making more money than
this guy but not only that the next year
some of these people might buy again
what do you know now our cost basis is
going to go up because obviously they're
buying something else right but so is
our absolute profit Uncle Warren for
example every single year for Seas
candies has raised the prices and that's
typically in accordance with costs of
cocoa and butter and and you know the
Commodities that actually create the
product but he has I think on average
and I'll have to look this up again but
I'm pretty sure on average like some of
the highest years were 177% increases
and that's like year-over-year but his
average was much higher than the price
index increases and so basically he was
able to continue to see that once
someone bought their chocolates they
would continue to buy them over and over
again even with a higher price which
then leads to okay from a repurchases
perspective he said this he said if you
buy your darling C candies for
Valentine's Day or her birthday or
whatever and you guys enjoy them
together he said we've got you for life
and the point there is that they now
cost they spent the money to acquire you
one time but then after that you keep
buying again and again and again and
again and that extends the LTV of the
person so you're getting more people
interested who are then going to buy at
higher prices so there's even more gross
profit per unit and they're going to buy
again and again and again I can hardly
imagine something that would be more
powerful for a business there's a
concept of the give to ask ratio and I
talk about it here in my leads book in
the content chapter and the reason that
this is such an important metric is
basically this is a history of
reinforcement how many times have you
reinforced positively before you ask for
something but this is the part that
people miss and it's because most
people's productss aren't that good
their ask in their mind is perceived as
a negative and the give is obviously
perceived as a positive and so you make
this media you give out this free stuff
that gives you more and more pluses some
people like to think about it like a
bank account you add more deposits and
then you can withdraw but when listening
to jobs talk about this he actually
purely talks about it from an asks
perspective he says if people buy our
product and they absolutely love it then
we have provided more value we put a
deposit into our relationship he said if
people buy our product and they hate it
or they was just mediocre then we've
withdrawn from that relationship this
whole idea of give ask many people talk
about this in terms of like content and
then monetization but it actually
extends all the way through the business
and in the perfect world you give in the
content and when you ask for money it
becomes a give because as soon as they
buy the product they're like oh my God
this is amazing which is why for example
I think that like I try to get people to
start with the books because it's the
thing that I've spent the most time on
and cost relative devalue is pretty
insane that allows me to give yet again
and create a positive history of
reinforcement with an audience Brands
compound over time not because
necessarily media compounds but media is
just a measurement tool for word of
mouth because like your audience will
grow because people will share your
stuff like try and get it down to the
people when analyzing these kind of like
amorphous ideas like what happens when a
brand grows it means you did a good
thing and then that person tells another
person and then that person experiences
the benefit themselves and then that
person tells another person and so the
output of the brand is the trust with an
audience that grows rather than logos
and color schemes and fonts like it's
none of that it's just how many people
trust me but the reality of building a
brand is that it's kind of like a
friendship like imagine meeting somebody
and being like we're best friends if
they said that the first time you met
you'd be like that's a bit weird right
and so building a brand is a lot the
same thing it takes time to build trust
and trust is predictive power based on a
past history of experience and so you
you have to develop that past history of
experience if if somebody did something
nice one time for you you're not
immediately going to be like oh I trust
this guy with my life it's like well he
did one thing but if he does thing after
thing after thing after thing after
thing for an extended period and then
makes an ass you're like well I kind of
owe him one he's done a bunch of stuff
for me right and so that's the ideas
that it just takes a long time now
here's where it gets where there is high
Arbitrage with brand with media and
Technology one person can give to a
million people at once in a very small
way and so the idea is okay how can I
give to a million people at once over
and over again even in a fractionalized
manner such that in 10 gives or 20 gives
or 50 gives I've now given effectively
three full gives or four full gives to
somebody so that they might be willing
to quote return the favor based on their
cultural rules and so in those four ways
building the brand makes you so much
money that you will have the first step
taken towards realizing it wasn't the
point to begin with the second way to
get so rich that you realize that making
money was never the point is to know the
inputs and outputs of your money-making
system and you want to break those down
to the absolute smallest action that way
you can scale it while sustaining your
margins so whenever LEL and I get
overwhelmed right because it happens all
the time you basically clear your plate
and then you add more stuff to your
plate and then you're like oh my God I'm
overwhelmed then you clear your plate
again and that's I honestly I think a
lot of that is just like
entrepreneurship when we look at our
plate what we do is I look at every
single activity that I'm doing on a
weekly basis and I say how does that tie
to how we make money and it's trying to
understand what are the inputs that
pushing into our money-making system and
are there things on here that are either
too indirect or just not actually
driving anything at all and so for
example I took over uh a department
recently and I cancelled all meetings
that were recurring where people were
just sharing data and the main reason
was that that that data was not being
used to change behavior and so either
the data is not correct or useful or we
need to learn how to do something about
that data and so if we spend all this
time going over data and doing nothing
about it then that time is completely
wasted both in the collection storing
and Analysis of data but then also the
reviewing it with a team of people and
so unless something changes what we do
we don't need to track it and so this
gets you much more targeted on the few
things that matter so shiron svat he's a
he's a public CEO he and I talked about
this at length he basically uh posits
that for every per every company it's
on/ tenth of the employees that are
actually creating the majority of the
economics in the business like there's a
core team that really is the one that
moves the whole machine and a lot of the
rest of the people are there more or
less for the ride and the idea is what
is it that those 10 people do what are
their inputs that drive this machine and
I think that being able to identify what
those activities are not the general
morphous words but what the actual
activities are like is it writing an
email is it writing ad copy is it
filming content or filing filming ads is
it reaching out to a certain amount of
people is it reaching out to customers
is it hopping on a certain number of
calls uh sales calls like all of these
are activities that will drive Revenue
in the business you basically look at a
lot of other stuff that many people will
fill their calendars with and the
majority of it doesn't make money and if
the point of a business is to generate a
profit through providing value to a
Marketplace outsid of the cost of
delivering that value then you want to
put as much into the value creation as
possible as little into the cost basis
as possible and do it as many times as
you can and everything that's not those
things ultimately detracts from the
efficiency of the system and so think
about it like this you have a
money-making system you have a box now
in that box is your general activities
of doing business so you sell tables you
sell books you provide services whatever
your thing is is you have a cost of
delivering that thing and you have a
price that should be above that cost and
then that discrepancy between those two
things is how you make money and you
spin that wheel as many times as you can
where this gets important is you have to
understand understand the inputs into
this system and you have to break it
down to activities like I can't explain
to you how incredibly powerful this is
to both understand this for yourself and
explain it to your team and be able to
revisit it on a regular basis because
the inputs will change and so for
example if I were to say hey Alex what
do you do what are the inputs in the
acquisition. commonym system there's
many things that Ur in acquisition.
comom but you as the founder or the
entrepreneur you're basically pushing
the first Dom over and then there's many
subsequent activities that happen after
and sometimes there's two or three
dominoes that are occurring that you're
pushing but what happens is when we
describe what we do we use lots of
amorphous words that have very little
connection to what we actually do for me
for example like what are the things
that I actually do my inputs for
acquisition. comom right so let's say
the acquis geez let's see if I can spell
my own company there we go acquisition.
comom um there you go.com oh God now
it's ugly as hold on there we go
there we go nice nice clean C there for
everybody see all right so I script
stuff okay cool I record that's
something that I do I check in on status
of stuff I review things and give thumbs
up or feedback I review deal metrics for
deals that we're considering doing in uh
acq uh.com or acq Ventures which is our
Venture arm we just started I present to
the team when we have kind of like New
Direction that we're taking I also
review portco
metrics and decide where the money goes
both within acquisition. comom and then
within the portfolio companies when I
say money I say generically like the
resources that we have so we're going to
allocate this person here we're going to
allocate these resources here and so
this is like what it actually is and
this is today now these things Shuffle
over time but you can notice here that
these are me describing actual
activities right so what you need to do
is now if I'm going to look at this
there's going to be some things that
feed them this machine and then there
going to be some things that are me
actually doing the stuff in the machine
and so this for example these are
feeders this stuff feeds in this is you
know me providing feedback me driving
stuff these are all for feeding this
machine is how do we get more attention
how do we get more business owners to
know about our stuff how do they you
know they can buy our books so they can
learn to trust us and then eventually
you know maybe there's a deal down the
line big picture we've got these feeders
that feed into this machine and then we
kind of have what I would consider these
are all the things of delivery right
these are how I how the actual machine
works and makes money the reason that
defining the inputs is so important is
that many times when you look at what
you actually do you aren't doing things
that drive an increase in number of
customers or an increase in LTV and so
if you think about this like this is the
LTV this is the number of customers and
you can basically Drive growth in only
those two ways and so you have to dial
in what is actually the thing that makes
money here and whenever you have a
deadline for example all of a sudden
your ability to to focus gets really
clear and I think the reason for that is
because you have no time to waste and so
most people do like spend like 90% of
their time on stuff that doesn't
actually drive the needle and then only
10% of the stuff when they actually need
to make money that does it but what
would happen if you actually spend all
of your time on the inputs that mattered
most for example I write two emails a
week for the mosy minute uh which is
what I send to the to the whole list
which is kind of like very tactical
business Concepts it's very high
leverage for me it takes me about an
hourish per email that I send and that
is something something that drives
awareness it drives business it drives
value it drives portfolio companies it
drives everything right and so that's an
input right and so it's betting very
clear on most of the things that people
do that are just not that and so
whenever you scale an input or like the
inputs that you have in terms of your
money-making system or the inputs of
what you do in order to feed that system
you essentially have three options for
scaling option number one is you can
automate so you can get a machine to do
it all right now some things are very
difficult to automate AI can automate a
lot sometimes in the future there will
be an AI version of me that can probably
make content better than I can and we'll
cross that bridge when we get there but
that would be something that could
happen the second is that you get other
people so that means that I'm having
somebody else then make this content for
me now there's I want to be very clear
there's degrees here a lot of people
like to think in binaries it's like okay
well can I get somebody else to script
this stuff can I get someone else to
check in can I get someone else to
record re review and give feedback so
then the only thing that I would have to
do is record yes of course I could and
so the idea is you don't necessarily
need to replace every single part of
what you do but you can just basically
chunk down the inputs into okay this one
someone else can handle this one someone
else can handle and then the final uh
component of this is that you can do one
to many now what does that mean if like
this is already a very leveraged
acquisition system right because it's me
one to many you're watching this it
takes me one time to say it but many
people can see it but if you had a a
one-on-one method of reaching out to
people say cold outbound as your way of
getting uh people in or maybe you get
Affiliates one-onone then you're either
going to have to automate that way of
getting Affiliates one-onone you're
going to have to get a team of people to
do it or you're going to have to switch
to a mechanism that allows you to
continue to do it but do it to many
people at once and so I think through
this whenever I have to kind of scale
any kind of delivery or marketing is is
this something that I can get other
people to do and this also works on the
back end right here so it's like okay
can I get other people to review
portfolio metrics can I get other people
to decide where the allocation is again
these things are very high leverage for
me meaning I don't have to put a lot to
get a lot from it and so it's worth me
developing that skill set even deeper
rather than potentially delegating it
but long term in my opinion every
business can be delegated it's just that
uh you have to find Stars and you have
to find people who are better than you
and often times that's tough like could
Steve Jobs delegate being Steve Jobs
well I don't know I mean they have yet
to really make anything as good as what
he made you know if Elon died would
would all of the companies do as well
without him I don't know that's where
it's like okay he has to automate or get
other people as many people as he can to
do all the other stuff and the stuff
that matters most to him like for
example he says all my companies have
zero marketing except for the fact that
they have the most popular men like in
history being the person who's running
them and when I say popular I just mean
it from an an absolute perspective
people know who he is when he makes a
tweet a gazillion people see it and so
if we were to we probably could add this
up and see what his total impressions
are per month both directly on X and
then also in terms of shared volume of
the amount of pages that share his
interviews and the Rogan stuff and
YouTube and so like there's no marketing
department because they have a oneman
marketing department that in of itself
is worth I mean billions of dollars and
so I see everybody as an individual
contributor at the most basic level like
everyone does things and they are just
either directly tied to some sort of
outcome that gets customers or makes
them worth more or they are not right
and so I would encourage you this is
especially for this is me talking
specifically to business owners right
now so there's three questions that I
like to ask an employee
number one what do you
do and they will use amorphous terms and
you're like no no no like not analyze
what do you do what does that mean right
until they can Define it in a way that
like okay you look at numbers on an
Excel sheet and you try and then you see
if some are above a certain threshold or
below it okay got it so that's what you
do
now do you know what I do or what we do
as a business now a lot of times people
can't even explain it back to you and
they work for you so if they certainly
can't explain it to you they're
definitely not doing something
necessarily that's going to help it all
right what do we
do and then here's the third question
how does what you do help what we do and
it ties what they do to the outputs of
the business and so fundamentally let's
say that someone says I am in finance
okay cool what do you do I compile and
tabulate our expenses versus what we
generate and when something looks above
Benchmark above our historic average I
flag it to make sure that it is worth
spending money on and if we do well in a
business line I flag it to see what we
did better and if we do poorly I flaged
to see why we did worse and so that is
what you produce now I would then say
how does what that does influence this
and this now the intelligent Finance
person would then say I influence the
decisions about what we spend to get
more customers and how we make them
worth more through doing more of the
things that increase value and taking
away things that add to costs and that
would be a very real answer as to tying
their inputs into the outputs of the
system and so you have to be able to
dial these things in first to connect
your actions to what makes a business
money and then scaling those actions
through automation other people or
gaining leverage on that activity I'll
give you three major money sucks that
people do that are not this so number
one is they will work on projects that
are not going to drive the main
objectives so it's like they want to
reorganize a AA in some way right or
whatever your project management thing
is okay we have this massive
reorganization fine okay great now it's
taking up a lot of time or you redo your
entire website which takes you a ton of
time but is it really the constraint of
the business is it the thing that's
going to generate money or you should
should you just split test your
headlines on your landing page right
like there are other things that will
drive more customers and so basically
like I can give you a list of a thousand
things that you could do to grow a
business the question is which one of
them will grow it the most and so most
people spend time on activities that
they enjoy that drive very little
business to the business but they can
mentally masturbate to the idea that
they're being productive because it's
business is it's related to business and
so it's like it's almost like they're
doing like arts and crafts and hobbies
while they're doing business but those
aren't the main drivers the second thing
is that they spend too much time on
meetings and this is a really common one
which is that people are social people
like to talk to each other and so if
they get an excuse to do it they will do
it one of the most frightening things in
the entire world which I recommend you
do is actually look at how much everyone
makes per hour so look at their annual
pay divided by 2,000 and then look at a
meeting when you when you have 10 people
on it right and then all of a sudden
you're like I paid
$500 for this meeting and if you went
out to dinner and took everybody to
dinner and then you paid $500 for dinner
people like oh my God thank you so much
it's so generous of you it's like every
meeting is that and so unless you can
show how this is going to generate US
$500 plus now mind you you need to get a
return on that so you probably need to
get something like four or five times
that amount amount of money from that
meeting then you probably just shouldn't
have it and where this gets really
really nasty is once your your business
gets big enough employees in general
start meeting with each other and so
it's like you're not even involved and
these these losses are occurring on a
regular basis sometimes people call it
time theft I don't think the intentions
there but I do think that the end result
is still the same which is that the
business becomes less efficient and
bears more cost to deliver the same
product the third big kind of like hole
that I see a lot of times is people who
spend an inordinate amount of time on
data that doesn't change what they do so
I'll give you an example I could track
what the temperature is of every room
that I walk into I could track the
amount of words that I say on a meeting
you could track anything right some
people especially small business owners
and sometimes even on your team will
just love to show you all these Excel
sheets of all this this data that
they've tracked it takes a huge amount
of time and they get all these
percentages and all these ratios and
then you just have to ask the question
why should I care about this how does
this change what we do and I ask this
question over and over and over again
because so many people love to be like
oh no we're data driven it's like are
you data driven or are you data
distracted and this is the limit test
this is the very easy limit test if this
number goes up does it change what we do
if this number goes down does it change
what we do if this number changing
doesn't change what we do we don't need
to track it when you ask that question
over and over again because people are
like well we want to keep an eye on that
I'm like why let's take it to the
Natural extreme why the world is
increasingly Quantified and being able
to with with automation and software and
wearables like there's so much
technology out there that wants to
quantify everything because they know
that people have an obsession with data
but not all data is useful and so most
businesses you can figure out the
metrics on the back of a napkin and
figure out if you like it or not that
back of napkin way of running a business
in my opinion is an exercise and thought
discipline of the entrepreneur if you
know the clear inputs that drive the
business which for you might just be I
have to script record and edit content
it could be I have to script record and
edit ads it could be I have to do a
certain amount of Outreach attempts or
manage a team to hold them accountable
to to doing these Outreach attempts like
there are certain number of things that
actually drive the business if the data
that you collect does not change what
you do with your inputs then you don't
need to track it you can reverse
engineer this to figuring out first what
are the inputs that actually drive the
output and then secondarily what data
would change how I do these inputs if
you find out that the CTR dropped on
your ads then you would probably change
your hooks you change you're targeting
that would change what you do so it
makes sense to track that if like number
of tags on a social platform you could
track it let's say it goes up in general
over a month what are you going to do
now you might say well I'll make more of
the content I made that month but if you
made a variety of different pieces of
content would you then have to track it
daily and see if there was a spike okay
I got more tags in this okay okay wait
stay with me how does getting more tags
translate into us making more
money I can show you a number of people
who get lots of tags tags and lots of
likes and lots of views that don't make
more money and so again it's not only
like maybe maybe it tracks to what we
would do but does does that track to us
making more money if you want to get so
rich that you question the meaning of
making money then the first thing you
can do is make sure that all of the work
that you do makes you more money and
stop spending time on things that make
you nothing although they are fun
distractions which leads me to the third
way of getting so rich that you realize
that making money was never the point
which is get other people to advertise
for you I remember the first time I ever
had someone else sell for me so I had to
go home for Christmas this was the first
year of owning my gym and had to go home
for Christmas I went home for Christmas
and uh this is why I was still going
home for the holidays while I remember I
was driving home and I got a call and I
had hired this uh sales gal and I had
taught her my script and we were still
running ads even though I was the one
selling and I had
I was the one who had done every single
sale since the beginning of the business
she sent me a text that was like oh I
went two for four and I remember I like
I got so emotional in the car while I
was driving that I felt like I almost
had to like pull over because I like I I
got got choked up because I was like oh
my God like this could actually work
without me and it was like the first
time where I realized that like this
could actually be a thing like it's not
just like Alex working really hard and I
have to make the money if no one else
makes makes the money then like like it
transitioned it was the first like
leading indicator of transitioning from
a job to an asset once I had that loop I
got really addicted to it I was like man
I wonder if there are people who could
train without me training I wonder if
there were people who like and I just
looked at all the things that I did and
that that that Obsession has not really
ended since then you have to get other
people to advertise for you in order to
have more leverage okay so Leverage is
about getting more for what you put in
and fundamentally like in my opinion all
of Entrepreneurship is mastering
leverage it's why it's core to our logo
for acquisition. comom this is a full
Chrome and because all of us have the
same inputs at the base level which is
time and so the people who get the most
for their time are the ones who get the
most money for their time by doing
activities that generate most Revenue
per minute or second imagine I had to
just get customers well at some point I
would max out the amount of hours per
day that I could spend doing it no
matter how efficient I get I'm going to
have to trade time to get it if I'm
doing it on a inputs outputs that are
directly correlated a one to one ratio I
can do the the ratio faster but I'm
still going to have that that connection
I can be more efficient in terms of
getting better at that skill but as long
as the base metric is still there I will
be capped based on hours per day so walk
you through four levels of this and I
talk about this in in in my leads book
which is the second half which is
talking about lead Getters all right so
I'll draw this out uh in real time for
you so you can actually get a voiceover
on it so basically at the very at the
very beginning imagine that you are
getting leads for your business okay so
this is just you all right and so let's
say you get 100 leads a day that you're
calling or you're reaching ing out to or
whatever now you can do this now your
work's going to be high and your
throughput is going to be fixed there's
nothing more you can do to it right now
the next level here is that you do this
thing but then instead of getting leads
you get a lead getter meaning you get
other people to advertise on your behalf
and so functionally instead of getting
like you reach out to 100 people you
then get someone else here's someone
who's not you Tada let's make him Smiley
there we go he's smiling he's very happy
to make you money okay so this person
now spends their time getting you leads
okay so we we just had to do this once
and then this created this node how I
like to think about it of lead
generation right and so boom this this
one day created this node ongoing so
who's more efficient the guy who just
continues to work here or the guy who
works gets one person and then that
person works on their behalf and doesn't
even have to do this he still gets the
same output all right you sticking with
me like look at our return here return
was 100 versus 300 in terms of units of
effort versus return but here we're
getting way more and every single month
this guy does more we still keep getting
a higher return on this initial base now
let's say that the next month you do
this and you get another guy right and
this guy gets you more leads so now
you're working the same amount you were
before but now we've tripled the amount
of well here we've doubled it because
you're getting lead Getters first but
the third day you'd have tripled it
right you keep getting more leads via
these other people that you've been
attracting and so there are different
types of lead Getters that you can bring
into a business you can bring employees
into a business so imagine I recruit
somebody and then I pay them to help me
make content I recruit somebody I pay
them to help me make media right of
course you can do that the alternative
is that you can go recruit an agency who
does this work on your behalf and the
only real difference there is just the
nature of the the pay relationship but
it more or less works the same way now I
will say this the businesses that grow
the fastest will typically have two
different types of lead Getters they
will have the lead Getters that come
naturally from their existing
advertising activities and so you let's
say are continuing to advertised to get
customers but these customers now become
lead Getters on your behalf they then
are the ones who are bringing more
people into your world and that is what
will end up compounding because over
time in order to have a compounding
business which is what you need in order
to get a really big business you can't
scale media indefinitely like at some
point like you will get such diminishing
returns that it won't make sense anymore
you have to eventually rely on Word of
Mouth mind you this is if you want to
get super rich if you want to just get
medium rich like you can make $10
million just knowing how to Market and
sell and just find people who don't know
who you are you can absolutely do that
but I'm trying to talk about getting
Mega rich and so you have to get
leverage over basically lots of other
people in a decentralized manner all
right so if you get employees or you get
agencies those are centralized those are
people you have direct relationships
with you have to scale that those those
relationships right whereas if you had
Affiliates which are other businesses
that basically operate independently
that have your have your customers and
then send you business or customers that
operate independently and then bring you
more business that decentralizes the
activity so that they continue to
advertise on your behalf far beyond your
ability to manage them right and this is
really setting up a system of incentives
such that they want to do it without
your prodding poking and uh well I guess
prodding and poking I don't know why
you're poking your customers Weirdo And
so a big visual here is that you've got
customers Affiliates employees agencies
right and so these are businesses these
are individuals these tend to be more
centralized these tend to be more
decentralized and the reason this is so
important is that like if you think
about how this flow works it's like
you're going to do the core 4 and these
are the inputs that we were just
referencing these are the puts and then
these are the outputs of those inputs
you're going to get employees you're
going to help you're going to get
customers you're going to help you're
get Affiliates or business owners who
then promote to their audiences right so
you tell other people about your stuff
and then other people use the core for
to do it on your behalf and so the more
times you can spin this wheel the more
customers you ultimately get in a
decentralized manner and if you want to
skip like if no one shared the content
that we have it would be very difficult
to grow a brand I would have to go
oneone and you can do that it's just
tough right now the people who don't
don't understand social media so like
sometimes you've seen like these old
school business guys like who just like
haven't realized like the world moved on
I see them all the time and so what they
do is they go and they will do one to
many they'll do like a a circuit of
in-person events now that's cuz they
realize that they have to get more
leverage so they just try and attend as
many of conferences as they can and it
totally is effective it's just a
different way of doing things but that's
their way of getting now if the LTV is
high enough you can still make a
tremendous amount of money in that
setting but if you are business to
Consumer business you're typically going
to need a decentralized manner of
acquiring customers so like for example
School needs a decentralized manner like
we have to have Affiliates which last
year 55% of all of our customers came
from uh Affiliates or referrals right
people with on the platform refer to
other people which is awesome and so
we're like you know like hey what if we
actually like tried to do this a little
harder and that's what we're doing this
year right and so the whole point
is you can either do it and you will get
capped or you can find a system that
allows or enables other people to do it
on your behalf so the first mistake of
getting lead Getters is having a bad
product and thinking that a good
incentive system is going to outweigh a
bad product imagine you go to a
restaurant and the sandwiches are
mediocre or soggy are not that good
right and then they say hey we'll give
you 50% off your next sandwich if you
tell your friends to come here we were
like I mean I just I don't want to tell
my friends to come here it's just not
that good right and imagine this let's
level up from a soggy sandwich just like
a mediocre sandwich if they say you get
50% off a sandwich if you get somebody
else are you still like are you going to
refer somebody for a mediocre sandwich
like I don't know probably not right and
so the big thing is is people try and
Jack more into the incentive when the
most efficient thing to do is just make
the product better because you want to
get it so that they this is just my this
is my two cents on this I want people
who are like I'm about to refer all my
friends cuz your product's really good
is there some sort of incentive that you
have that I can get paid for it and so
it's like I want people who already want
to be doing this anyways and then maybe
reach out and ask so I can just
lubricate the incentive system more so
than go from zero to one I want to go
from like one to n like I was going to
refer people already but with this
incentive I'll refer everyone that's
where this really gets magical rather
than trying to use the incentive as the
0o to one and I think me too like me
personally I also probably in my earlier
day spent too much time on like how do I
give even crazier incentives rather than
how do I just make the thing better so
that's thing number one is like if if
people don't want to refer your product
it's typically because the product's not
that good and so like we can obsess you
can read every referral booking in the
world you want but it's always going to
still come down to how good the sandwich
is so the second big mistake for getting
lead Getters is a poor incentive now
think about this is like a good product
requires low activation energy like
there are some products that are just so
good that you want the credit you're
going to get from your friend by telling
them about how amazing these sandwiches
are they don't need to give you a dollar
for every person you refer you'll just
do it because you want your friend to
think you're awesome because you turn
them on to this great spot but the
incentive AXS is a little bit of a
counterbalance so let's say that you've
got a seven out of 10 product but if
you've got a 10 out of 10 incentive
system you're still going to have a lot
of people referring you business right
and so I mean there's some businesses
that do have mediocre products but they
have exceptional affiliate programs
where they basically Affiliates make so
much money selling their product that
it's almost like their main product and
I think that most people think their
incentive is good and it's just not that
good like you giving 20% to somebody or
50 % off the next sandwich is just not
that good of an incentive now if I said
if you get a friend here to try my
sandwich that's mediocre and I'll give
you sandwiches for Life I'll probably
get people to prefer more people to get
sandwiches right but the thing is is
like it can't be it can't be so big that
people are like hey just eat the damn
sandwich for me so that I can get this
incentive because then you're you're
you're you're circumventing the whole
point of this the point is that they buy
the product they try the product they
like it and they buy it again right
that's the point and so a lot of times
we try and Jerry rig our way around
around solving the main thing but the
core economics of every business are
always going to come down to how good
the product is and so like this is
something that has taken me way too long
to realize and I think the reason it
took me so long to realize is I got
really good at marketing and sales early
that was kind of my my foray into into
the business world like I mean obviously
had my gyms but I you know the first
offer I ever really ran was still the
greatest offer that's run in the gym
industry for the last like 12 years or
13 years like and so like I I wrote a
rocket as my first try and so in some
ways like I got lucky on my first shot
and so I did what most people would do
which is like I had a very fast feedback
loop of reward for doing that so I did
more of that thing and I did it harder
and I did it better but you can only
spin the marketing wheel so many times
because at some point you will run out
of customers and if your sandwiches
aren't good you'll have just told the
marketplace very quickly very
aggressively that you're mediocre and
that's what you want to avoid and so
like I remember hearing people talk
about this who are further ahead of me
saying like marketing is just gasoline
it'll just like let it'll do whatever
you're doing faster so like if you suck
it'll just let more people know that you
suck faster the problem is that it
doesn't take into account numbers
meaning like you can tell a lot of
people that you suck really fast and
still make a profit and this is
fundamentally why I think like the
education space the information space
gets a very bad name and it's because
like if once you know how to Market and
sell you absolutely can make millions of
dollars and you can deliver a pretty bad
product which I try to do my very best
to try to reverse that Trend and give a
very good product with the things that
we educate like grab the books like
they're my biggest gift I can give you
like but big picture I I am a I'm a
product of the alternative education
space like I didn't learn all these
things from college I learned these
things from other business owners who
taught me specific skills that I was
able to Cobble together and piece
together into building businesses that
made money but the thing that I didn't
learn until much later and honestly the
best people to to to consume product
stuff from is in Silicon Valley like
listen to software people talk about
product they're obsessive about product
and there's a reason that some of the
biggest companies in the world are all
product driven tech companies and it's
because product gives you the most
leverage right because if you think
about it you can like you could
conceivably not do any promotion you
have to do enough to get the first users
of course right but once you have those
first users if those users then continue
to advertise on your behalf these so
like this is where you get the most
leverage this guy this guy brings you
another another guy who does the does
the promotion for you right this is and
now like think about this like imagine
this doesn't exist so this doesn't exist
anymore this doesn't exist anymore all
you did was make the best damn sandwich
you've ever made for somebody and this
guy tries a sandwich and he's like man
this sandwich is num right I don't know
he's he's a weirdo he says n I'm a lot
and so he has it and then he says dude
I'm going to tell all my friends about
this and what people don't realize about
referrals is that they typically are not
like a one:1 ratio so it's not that like
every person refers a person it's
typically like one out of 10 people
refers 10 people and so we have these
kind of like micro influencers within
their Network that they have enough
trust that people will listen to them
like if Alex goes and get sandwiches
like I'm a bit of a sandwich uh a ficado
if you will I do I do love me a good
sandwich and so if I'm like dude this
place is great I don't give compliment I
don't give cheap compliments and so if I
say that then a lot of people are like
well one he's had a lot of sandwiches to
he doesn't say that most sandwich Ops
are good and he has the means to buy
whatever sandwiches he wants and so he
probably has high his his recommendation
carries weight right and if I
recommended a sandwich shop in the past
and it was good then they will even be
more likely this is where brand comes in
more likely to listen to my referral
again and so the problem for the
business owners is that we don't know
which guy is going to be the 10 like
which of the 10 is going to be the one
guy and so that means that you just have
to overd deliver for everyone
understanding that nine out of 10 aren't
going to be the person who's the Magic
referrer I got very lucky with my first
store at United Fitness at the time was
Transformation Center Huntington Beach
uh was my first gym I think in the first
10 customers one of the customers that I
signed up in that first two weeks I
think brought me like 20 more customers
and I'm telling you for a small business
owner like it was I mean it was like the
difference between making rent and not
making rent and it was a nurse who knew
all these other nurses and and her she
brought her hair stylist in she brought
her friends in she brought other nurses
from work in like she brought everybody
in she brought her like she brought
everybody in and I was like man this is
so cool and you just want to look at
what happened with that person that Happ
on accident and do it on purpose for
everyone so that when that next Super
referrer comes in you're ready the third
big mistake is not reinvesting and so
I'll explain what I mean by this so if
you decide that you're going to have a
referral strategy or an affiliate
strategy is the primary of getting
business which I honestly think that you
should figure that out with a business
like it is the way that you create a
compounding business that is viral in
terms of its acquisition and as you
scale any company especially BTC you
need word of mouth and at the very least
the nice thing is that word of mouth for
product also translates into retention
so if somebody refers Somebody To You
the likel that they stay and continue to
pay you is pretty high and even if
someone doesn't refer to you if you
structured something that was so good
that most people do refer the likely
that people who don't refer still
continue to stay and pay is still also
high and so you end up solving for both
acquisition and retention with the same
core activities which for me is like
high leverage right like if you fix the
product you get more customers and you
get the the customers who stay to buy
more once you find an affiliate system
or referral system that works it's just
letting it go on autopilot and I think
that is a mistake and so like I I
mentioned earlier like school for
example we like we did a lot of things
this year to promote it and then we saw
that 55% of our our customers came from
Affiliates and so now we're like
doubling down we're like how can you
make this even easier how can you
lubricate the process how can you remove
steps how can we give them more training
how can we you know like how can we just
make this even higher likelihood that
people who already have a low threshold
because they like the product we just
lower the activation they need even
lower so that more people can hop over
and bring business our way I told you at
the beginning that would give you three
ways to get so rich that you'd realize
that making money was never the point
and so the first way is that you build a
brand and the translation of that into
making money is that you get more people
to click on whatever you do for your
advertisements you get more of them to
buy you get them to buy at higher prices
you get them to buy more times all of
those compound into lower cost per
customer and more lifetime value per
customer the two primary ways of growing
a business the second way is that you
track your inputs and outputs so that
you do more of the things that actually
generate more customer customers and get
your team to do more of those things
that actually generate more customers or
get them to be worth more and basically
remove everything else and avoid all the
mistakes and pitfalls that people get
time sucked into that don't actually
move the needle the third is getting a
higher leveraged way to get customers
which is getting lead Getters so that
they can get customers on your behalf
and basically every Mondo business
you've ever seen has this and if you're
like man Alex that's hard welcome to
becoming Super Rich there's a reason
that that many people have it and so you
have to find ways to get leverage and
the strongest way is to build an
exceptional product the second strongest
way is to have an amazing incentive and
then the third best way is that when you
have a great product or a great
incentive that you reinvest in the thing
that's making it work and when you do
all three you will make the amount of
money because you have this amazing
brand you know the inputs that generate
those types of returns and you will
continue to reinvest in higher and
higher leverage ways of getting
customers to get you more customers so
that eventually it's decentralized and
it grows on its own without you it
becomes a monster that you have to feed
rather than dog that you have to pull by
the neck to grow and there's this great
visual analogy for what this feels like
at the end so they say this in y
commentator and I just love it which is
in the beginning a startup feels like
pushing a boulder up a hill and then as
soon as you get product Market fit which
is where the customers tell their
customers about the product you start
getting referrals and that wheel starts
spinning it feels like you're chasing
the boulder down the other side of the
Hill running after it and so I love that
visual because that's where you want to
get and to be clear it's painful on both
sides it's just most people would prefer
the pain on the other side of the hill
so I'll get real for you a second I you
know I'm 35 now so the the numbers go
over here now and I had a big kind of
existential crisis right around this age
when I sold uh Jim and Prestige labs in
Allen uh for 46.2 million and well Allen
was sold separately but whatever and my
big realization was okay I no longer
materially need to make money like I can
just sit this thing in a treasury and
live on a few million dollars a year
doing absolutely nothing and that ended
up making me really sad and I'll I'll
explain something that that may be real
for some of you which is I remember when
I was in college the the Powerball
lottery had gotten over a billion
dollars and so I went and I bought a
ticket with my girlfriend at the time it
was more just cuz it was like fun it
wasn't cuz I thought I was going to win
but when the drawing actually happened I
remember having this moment of sheer
dread where I was like What if I win and
the dread was that if I won I would
never have had a shot to prove that I
was good enough and that the only reason
I was successful was because of luck and
even if I built success with the cash
that I got from the lottery it would it
would basically be meaningless now you
could talk about all the self-work you
want there of like well you should you
should take a billion dollars if someone
offers you a billion dollars yeah I
think you should but I still wanted to
have the shot of being able to prove
that I could do it and I really wanted
to prove it to me I think more than
anything else and when I did lose our
remember feeling relieved of course I
didn't hit the billion dollar Powerball
but selling my company for a material
amount of money so much that I didn't
have to work anymore it did help me
realize that making money was never the
point it was just a way of measuring
whether I was doing a good job in the
thing that I was building and so it's
over basically an entire year of me
being relatively sad because I didn't
know what to do and so sadness is as I
Define it a lack of perceived options
which is you don't know what to do it's
why I feel so hopeless you don't know
what you don't know what actions to take
which is why you just want to stay in
bed and do nothing anxiety by the way is
the exact opposite of that which is you
have many you have many options and no
priorities that's why it's like you you
have many things you could do but you
don't know which one to start with and
so for me it was definitely sadness at
that time and so it took me that whole
whole year of the sale which is right
here this year is when I sold to realize
that hard work for me was the goal and
so I want to take this quick second to
to make this point which is that I get a
amount of flack for talking about how I
work and I want to be clear do whatever
you want like I just know that when I
didn't work I was very sad and when I
work I'm much happier and so I work and
if you don't aren't that way then that's
amazing like you won I talk about what
worked for me and I talk about that
because it would have been helpful for
me to hear somebody else who was like me
say these things like it will be hard
regardless I mean I think a big part of
the suffering that I've had has come
from thinking that things should be
different than they are like I should be
happier I should be like I think most of
human discontent comes from thinking we
should be happier than we are we just
have an expectation of the universe that
that life should always be happy but
it's like it's it's so rare that that
occurs and I've gotten significantly
more feelg Goods out of looking back at
what I've done and being proud of myself
and I think that that's something that I
can kind of chew on day after day after
day even if what my day-to-day is isn't
always funny games you know what I mean
like if I have to record Another Piece
of content cuz I'm like oh okay we got
to do that then I do it you know what I
mean but and and I'm okay with that but
it's because I I like the output of that
I like the amount of businesses that I
see that have come that been like dude I
had my job I read your first book and I
made $100,000 I read the second book we
got $2 million this year like I love
that stuff and I'll die and no one will
care and we'll all move on in weeks and
that'll be it and so I live this way
because when I looked back on the years
when I was at this point and I knew I
didn't need to make any more money I
looked at the happiest moments of my
life when I looked back and the happiest
moments was when I was going through it
was like when I was working and I had
this very there's this saying that I
really like a lot which is like you're
always going through the good old days
when I was going through it like you
know I could tell Leila like man
remember when we were like broke as
and trying to make this work it's like
yeah it's like you look back
nostalgically on those moments during
the moment it's tough but when you look
back it's actually like some of the
Fondest Memories you have and and so
reframing the fact that like all of my
Fondest Memories were during my hardest
times I then was like well shoot maybe I
should reframe how I see hard maybe I
should pursue hard things and so that's
what became my kind of like my life
thesis which was hard work is the goal
like I want to leave nothing in my tank
I want to I I want to leave on empty
right I want to have nothing left like
those are the days that I enjoy the most
is that I I work at the end I'm like I I
know I can look back on my day and be
like I moved all of these things forward
and to me that's meaningful and to other
people might not be and if you're like
why don't want to work like like don't
like by all means don't for the love of
God don't do whatever you want like if I
had if I had one big message it's like
do whatever you want like the Queen of
England died a year ago or whatever it
is and you haven't thought about her but
she was like one of the most significant
female monarchs of all time she was one
of the wealthiest people to ever exist
and you haven't thought about her until
me saying this right now think about
your great great-grandfather you
probably haven't thought about him until
right now in this moment and no one's
going to think about you either like it
takes three generations for you to be
completely forgotten where you see
pictures of your relatives and you don't
know anyone in the picture they're just
humans to you right and we're going to
be humans to other people and so I think
in some way it actually it's a really
nice like humanitarian angle which is
that like in four generations like one
everybody who's in your progeny is so
far removed in terms of Gene poool that
they've been mixed with other people so
much they are so much greater not you
than they are you that like it's just
humans right and so like in some ways
like we're all family not to get all
Kumbaya on you but like in a lot of ways
we are and so I'm good with making stuff
that helps a bunch of people and using
whatever unique genetic predisposition I
have which is like I'm willing to work
for a long period of time I don't lose
focus very easily I can keep kind of
working for extended periods of time
without losing energy and so like I do
that and there are some people who are
painters and there's some people who are
musicians and like they contribute in
their way but I think that I will always
have respect for anyone who works their
ass off it's just one of those things
like like you might not like him you
might not like what he does you can't
say the guy doesn't work his ass off I
was talking to a friend the other day
and he brought this up he's like hey man
I think I think your content is sounding
like a little hardcore right now and
when people meet you in person he said
like the number one thing they tell me
is like he's a lot nicer than I thought
he was and he's like kind of funny and
cracks jokes and stuff and I heard that
and he was like I think when you you
started out like people think that you
just do this to make money now and I
also say that to be clear so that I have
brand coverage which is if I just say
I'm only here to make money then no one
can get ever upset that I make money I
think where people get in trouble is
where they're like I only do this
because I want to love Humanity it's
like well if you do that then never make
money fine just give it all way for free
like you basically you set yourself up
for a trap to be destroyed later so
that's why I say that now is it possible
to both make money and do things that
help people yeah I think that's the
nature of capitalism like when I had
this period of time right here where I
was like what am I going to do with my
life I originally thought I was going to
start a charity that was my whole that
was like going to be my whole angle and
the the more I thought about it the more
I thought that Charities were not
sustainable they they can't feed
themselves right you have to keep always
asking for more money really begging
people for money so that they can like
care about your cause but basically it's
an inefficient allocation of capital
like you take from one side you give to
another but in order for something to be
sustainable it has to it has to have a
cycle and so then I ended up reading
this book by John Mackey called
conscious capitalism and to be really
clear I think I only read the first
third and I was like this is whatever
anyways I I I like I was like I I get
the point of the book so basically it's
just that in order to have something be
sustainable it needs to benefit all
stakeholders it has to it has to benefit
the investors it has to benefit the
employees it has to benefit the
environment it has to benefit the
customers it has to benefit everyone and
so I essentially like rederived
capitalism from from from from base
units of like how do I do good how do I
do good in a sustainable way oh I need
to have a business that does good but
because it does good it generates a
profit because there's value to all
stakeholders and so fundamentally like
that's why I had this whole like okay
well then I'll just give lots of value
here which will create these businesses
or attract businesses to then invest in
and then that will be the cycle I get
when you're broke like it's very hard to
think about other people but you will
end up getting to that point now
everyone's numberers different some
people are like I just want $10 million
some people just want $1 million some
people want a billion dollars like
everyone's different in terms of your in
terms of your uh requests of the
universe but I will say something that
basos said which is that small
expectations are a self-fulfilling
prophecy and so like if you shoot small
you win small and so if you're if
shooting if shooting's going to take the
same cost either way it's going to be
hard and it's going to take time and
years and effort it's like I think Peter
steel said this he said if you want to
compete open a restaurant in Chicago you
can just do that if you want if you also
want the monetary goal which I just like
because it just shows me how how if I'm
improving in the game and back to what
my friend was saying at the very
beginning he said I don't think a lot of
people understand that you just actually
just like love business and I think
that's like I I just so happen to have
fallen in love with something that
rewards financially but like my LPM test
for this is that I actually don't have
tremendous affinity for any one business
I'm not like oh I love I love sneakers I
love I love insurance I love whatever I
love software like I I just kind of like
love business and I think trying to fit
myself into a box caused me a lot of
pain and suffering and so I will like
when I think about the the the moments
where time stands still it's when I'm
talking to a business owner about their
business about how it works and I get to
ask like a million questions I'm like oh
what are the margins on that oh and like
when I ask questions they're super
invasive because I'm just like how much
profit do you make like what what do
your return on ads spend like what's
your conversion look like what's the
like and I ask all these things and some
people thinks I'm like I'm trying to
steal their stuff I'm like oh I have no
desire but I I just want to understand
it and so I think that's why like I
write books about this stuff I make
videos about this stuff I draw pictures
about business because it's it's what I
love and it just so happens to be
something that makes money and that is
why like if I were if I were playing
video games all day no one would care
and it's just because there's a wider
percentage of people that can play video
games all day and people understand it
it's just that fewer percentage of
people understand that I would work all
day and talk about business all day
because why would you ever want to do
that well it's just like I feel like I
have this very odd enoy like I have this
like I have this like business fetish
and I remember because I was very
obsessed with Fitness for like over a
decade I was I was I competed like I was
very into fitness like and I'm a pretty
obsessive person and so enough that the
people that I worked with were like dude
like please quit here and and and start
start something Fitness related and so I
ended up doing that cuz they were like
dude I can't hear you talk about Fitness
anymore like it's so annoying but the
thing here's the crazy part two weeks
into starting the the Fitness business I
had once I had my gym I realized that I
loved business more than I loved Fitness
and I love Fitness a lot and I still I
still work out to this day but I loved
business even more and that was weird
for me because I was like I'll never
like anything more than Fitness there's
no chance and until I found it and so if
you are fortunate enough to love a
specific problem or love a specific
Avatar by all means like my hope is that
Just Lose Yourself to that romantic love
and just go all in on it but I am
hardcore I'm willing to be hardcore in
my content even for the sound bites even
though I know it makes me look more
binary more black and white than I
really am because I think that for the
younger version of me that was out there
that was like I felt very misunderstood
I felt very lonely was like I just want
to work all the time and I want to work
on weekends and I want to work in the
morning and I want to work while I'm
awake basically and it's because it's
the thing like it's the thing I'm into
and I I had a lot of suffering when
people would judge me on it and would
tell me that I was doing something wrong
and then like I was unbalanced or like
and and it's really tough when you don't
have the proof to show that you're good
at it yet and that's what it was for the
I mean like these are years guys like
this isn't this isn't like six weeks six
month like this these are years and I
started here right like like the years
and so I bring this up because like you
might be on year three year three is
before this graph even starts for me to
put this in context like this is year
four for me like 26 this was year four I
started too and so I I bring this up
because like you're not on the wrong
path you're just early hey guys this
channel grows and helps more people when
you guys share it and so if you found
this video valuable or have found it
valuable so far it would mean the world
to me if you shot as a text or you
shared it on your you know your
Instagram stories or you made a post
about it it helps more people see it and
ultimately hopefully change their lives
for the better if you like this then
you'll like these two other videos on
making lots of money and finding
meaninglessness in life once you do it